>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Good afternoon and welcome
to the Fiction Pavilion.
I suspect that welcome as
redundant 'cause I suspect many
of you have been glued
to your seats all day.
My name is Jonathan Yardley.
I'm the book critic
of the Washington Post
which is-- [Applause].
Thank you very much.
The Post has been, since
its inception in 19--
2001, the Post has been an avid
and very influential supporter
of the National Book Festival
and we'll continue to be as long
as the book festival exists, which
I suspect will be a very long time.
Four years ago, in the course
of my reviewing duties,
I stumbled across the bound
galley proofs of a book called,
"The Dream Life of Sukhanov."
I have never heard of
its author, Olga Grushin
and I'm not particularly well versed
in contemporary fiction coming
out of what was until
recently the Soviet Union.
But this looked like a particularly
interesting and provocative book.
And it turned out to be really
one of the best works of fiction
that I have read in
a very long time.
I ended up choosing it as one
of my best books of the year.
And I can assure you that
come December of this year,
I will be choosing Olga Grushin's
second novel, "The Line,"
as one of my best books of the year.
It seems to-- she makes
me think of Joseph Conrad.
She writes beautiful English in
what was not her native language.
She was born in Moscow
and she, rather than I,
is going to tell you a bit about
her absolutely fascinating life.
Olga?
[ Applause]
>> Thank you so much.
It's an honor to be here.
Thank you so much for coming.
And thank you so much for
this wonderful introduction.
I feel that anything
that will follow
from you will probably
diminish my image as a writer
in everyone's eyes, so the best
thing to do probably is to just get
up and proceed to the signing.
But, I'll try.
[Laughter] I was born in Russia
and-- in a family of writers.
So, I always knew that
I wanted to write.
I come from 3 generations
of nonfictional writers,
journalists, and scholars.
My first auditory memory
really was my father banging
on his manual typewriter and
my mother closing the door
to his study saying,
"Father is working."
And I knew from the time when I was
a baby that working meant writing.
So for me, this was really
part of my genetic makeup.
I learned to read and write
when I was very young, 4 or 5,
mainly by pestering my much older
brother, then in high school,
as he was trying to do his homework.
And then, I proceeded to
write my first short stories
and fairy tales and poems.
And there is a well-acknowledged
tendency of first time novelist
to turn to autobiographical
material for their first novel.
And my first novel, "The Dream
Life of Sukhanov" which came
out 4 years ago used
Moscow of the '80s which is
where I grew up as the background.
But really, it didn't have any
other autobiographical similarities
with my life that protagonist is a
56-year-old artist, a man who gives
up his art to become an art
critic, a kind of a bureaucrat
from the arts under pressure.
And people sometimes ask
me, "How did you manage
to avoid the whole autobiographical
impulse with your first book?"
Well the truth is I didn't.
The really first book that I
wrote was published when I was 7.
We had a family tradition.
Every year, starting when I was 7,
I would write a book
length work of fiction.
And my father would
type it up and bind it.
I would illustrate it.
And we would give it to
my mother on her birthday.
And that first story was called,
"The Tale of a Lazy Princess."
And in this story, there was a
princess who really didn't want
to learn how to make her bed and
how to cook her family breakfast.
Until her father, who was a very
stern king, makes her do it.
And then, later on she gets
kidnapped by a dragon who threatens
to eat her unless she
cooks his breakfast.
And if she burns his omelet,
she will be in trouble.
So, that stands her on good stead.
So this was very autobiographical,
except for the dragon part.
[Laughter] And everything
else was quite true.
So, I always knew that
I wanted to write.
What I did not know was that
I would write in English.
And that came about
quite unexpectedly.
After I graduated from high school,
I enrolled at the Moscow
State University.
Of course, at Journalism
Department which is what everyone
in my family-- literally everyone,
father and mother,
brother, had done.
But then, as was the height of
Perestroika, and it just so happened
that I was given a scholarship,
or I was offered a
scholarship at Emory University.
And this was in '89 and I would be
the first Soviet citizen to come
and get a 4-year American degree.
And of course, it was an
opportunity that I couldn't refuse.
So I came to America.
And, then one thing led to another.
I got a job.
I got married.
I had children.
And throughout all these
time, I continued to write.
Of course, it was a passion of mine.
But I wrote in Russian and I wrote
as the Russian expression goes,
into the drawer which basically
means for your own eyes only.
And at some point, a couple
of years after graduation,
it suddenly occurred to me that if
I really wanted to pursue my dream
and if I really wanted
to see myself published,
I would have to switch languages.
And this came when I
was about 23 or 24.
And then I started thinking about
what writing really meant to me
or what made a great work
of literature on my mind.
And to me, there have
to be 2 things.
One is a powerful story, and
by that, I don't mean a plot.
A plot is very nice.
It goes back to the whole
tradition of writer as entertainer.
You know, people sitting around
the fire after a successful hunt,
eating their fresh burro,
whatever and listening to the tale
of [inaudible], The Mighty fighting
the giant or something like that
and wondering what bated breath if
the giant is gonna get [inaudible]
or [inaudible] is going
to get the giant.
So, there is that and
it's important.
But what I mean by story is not the
outward plot, but the inner story
which to me really means the
story of a human soul on trial,
the search for a meaning
of life, if you will.
And let's not settle for less.
It's kind of what great literature
boils down to in my mind.
But the other no-less
important aspect is language.
I think language is the
way we organize our world.
And if you as a writer are hoping
to create your own artistic world,
you have to start with language.
You have to reinvent
it, recreate it,
and come up with a
language uniquely your own.
And at this point, I have
worked on precisely that,
crafting my own language
for almost 2 decades
but in a different
language, in Russian.
And so it was quite
traumatic, and at first,
devastating to suddenly give it up
and start literally
from scratch, from zero.
But then, I felt this really
doesn't have to be a drawback.
This does not have to
be an impoverishment.
This could be a enrichment,
in a way.
I could try to bring my Russian
culture and my Russian traditions
and the Russian language
into what I do in English.
And I will say a couple of
words about my recent novel.
My most recent novel
is called, "The Line."
It was published this year.
And it was inspired
by a real life story.
Both of my novels are set in Russia,
although this one is set in a kind
of a dream escape of
Russia in a way.
I was actually working
on a different book as
things often happen.
I was researching what I
thought would be my second novel.
And in the course of doing research,
I came across this
astonishing true story,
the visit of Igor Stravinsky
to Russia in 1962.
I've heard details of it of
course growing up in Russia.
But this was the first time I
sort of saw this story in print.
Igor Stravinsky left Russia
in 1912 before the revolution.
And he never went back.
He spent his whole life in exile in
France and Switzerland and America.
And when he was 80 years old,
Russia was undergoing the process
of liberalization [inaudible].
And Khrushchev invited him
back for a series of concerts
for the first time in 50 years.
This was to be his sort
of triumphant return home.
When people in Leningrad heard that
he was coming to this performance,
they lined up to buy
tickets to the performance.
And they 0waited a
line for the tickets
for a whole year and
that's a true story.
They really waited for a year
to buy tickets to one concert.
And that line emerged
as a sort of evolved
into this very elaborate system of
lists and kind of its organization.
It became its microcosm with its own
leaders and its whole relationships.
And I thought, what an amazing--
what a fascinating story.
It's such a metaphor of a power
of art in our lives in many ways.
And it touched so many
things in me, the--
Stravinsky's music which I love
because I love that whole period,
the early 20th century Russia war.
There was such a blossoming across
the arts and art and music and dance
and literature, and such brightness
that just suddenly exploded.
But also that very
image of the line,
it touched something in my youth.
I waited in many lines when
I was growing up in Russia.
But they were not the
lines that people hear
about when they think
of Soviet lines.
There were not lines for
bread and toilet paper.
The lines that I waited in
were-- are Perestroika lines.
And they were the lines-- precise I
like the lines for Stravinsky ticket
when suddenly, we started getting
artists we've never seen before
and musicians we've
never heard before.
>> And people would line up to
buy tickets to these concerts.
And the atmosphere in these lines
were-- I mean, it was amazing.
It was so palpable, the feeling that
you are next to kindred spirits.
People who have the same interests
as you do, who are willing to give
up hours if not days of their time
to see a performance,
to see paintings.
You met people in those lines.
You talk to people.
There was this air of excitement.
You made friends.
I met my first boyfriend
in a line just like that.
And it's sort of--
it touched something
in me on this very deep level.
And then I abandoned
very shortly the novel
that I thought I was researching
because this book would not let me--
this image of the line
would not stop haunting me.
And I wondered about people who
would give up not just some hours,
but who would literally give
up a year of their life,
was it just their love of music?
Was there something more?
And what did they get in return?
What did the line become for them?
At what point did it stop being this
collection of anonymous strangers
and became a community and
with its own friendships
and its own relationships
and its own antagonism,
it's own little world.
And so, what I wrote is
not a historical novel.
It is not set in '62 and the
composer is not Stravinsky.
My composer's name is Igor Selensky.
And it's kind of almost
like a parallel Russia.
Because what I wanted to tell
is really a fable about hope,
a fable about our human desires.
And I wanted to borrow elements
of the dark '30s and Russia,
Stalinist oppressions, but
also this hopeful excited--
exciting '60s and also more
sort of a stagnant '70s
and I borrowed these elements from
different periods to suit my story.
And at the heart of-- at the book,
there lies this mysterious kiosk.
There's a very much an element
of absurdity in the book, Kafka,
or if you know the wonderful
Russian Soviet writer,
Daniil Kharms who is one
of my favorites or Ionesco
or Beckett, always good people.
There is the kiosk
that never quite opens
and people don't know
what it's going to sell
and someone appears every
once in a while in the kiosk.
And there are rumors flying about
but no one quite knows
what is going to happen.
And yet, they still wait.
And then the rumor slowly
spreads about this concert,
a performance to be given
by this returning artist,
as returning composer of brilliance.
And at the heart of the
book is a family of 4.
There is a mysterious
grandmother who is silent, except,
she suddenly speaks up to years
of silence to request for a reason
that no one knows at first a
ticket to this performance.
And then, there are 3 other
family members who wait and shifts
at the kiosk ostensibly
on her behalf.
Her daughter Anna, a schoolteacher,
her daughter's husband,
who is a tuba player in a state band
but dreams of hearing great music,
and their teenage son, who
turned on the course of the book.
And these 3 people who wait in line,
they are ostensibly getting
the ticket for the grandmother,
but in the course of the book, they
start wanting the ticket for or--
or half from the very beginning,
wanted the ticket for themselves,
for reasons of their own.
And these reasons sort of developed
and eventually it's these sort
of clashing desires that form
much of the conflict of the book.
And I think I'd like
to take some questions,
what I'll do right before questions
is I'll read just a very short
segment, just one page to
give you a taste for the book
and to show you how I sort of
draw on my Russian traditions
and pay tribute to
the Russian greats.
This is a segment from the
first part of the book.
The narrative alternates
between 3 different voices.
There is the mother
Anna, the husband--
I mean the wife, the
husband and their son,
and then the grandmother's
voice, just sort of weaves in
and out of the narrative.
This section is the
husband's section, Sergei.
He's the one who is in
a way a failed composer.
He had childhood dreams of
composing beautiful music.
He ends up playing tuba
in a dismal state band.
He dreams of playing and
possibly creating beautiful music.
So for him, this concert
becomes this possibility--
this window into the world
of music and art and beauty.
And at this point, he's
waiting at the kiosk.
Nothing happens.
The kiosk is not open.
There's not of any sign over it
and he gets up and walks away.
And this is the segment and
for those of you who've read,
"War and Peace," you'll
recognize the illusion.
There's a famous scene of Andrew
in a battlefield when he falls
down wounded and he
sees the sky above him.
And he ignores the battle raging
around him and he notices the sky
and what he sees on
the sky is silence.
So this is sort of my
paraphrase of Tolstoy's scene.
[Pause] Sergei was already
at the next intersection
when a small beat-up
van labored past him.
His heart quickening, he turned,
followed it with his eyes.
The van pulled up to
the curb by the kiosk.
He swallowed an incoherent thwarted
gasp and just as the dented door
of the van began to jerk open,
dashed back and instantly tripped
over his shoelaces and started to
fall, but somehow righted himself,
and vaulting forward, slipped
on the ice and fell again.
And this time kept falling,
skidding, sliding in a flurry
of snow, closing his eyes against
the dazzling what confusion,
fully sprawled in his
back now, coming at last
to a blind whirling stop.
For a moment, he did not move.
Then deciding that nothing
was broken, he opened his eyes
and was just attempting to
scramble up when he saw the sky.
The sky was pale and empty and vast.
And it appeared to float ever higher
in transparent layers gradually
bleached of all blue tints
and shadows until at some
vertiginous unimaginable height,
it seemed to him bled of all color,
of all confusion, intense and pure
like the essence of one
sustained crystal note.
He lays still and looked at it.
The van door slammed shut,
and 2 pairs of legs crossed his
appended horizon at odd angles.
The first pair ending
with black shoes,
possibly imported, stepped over him.
The second, clumsy
in felt boots circled
around encumbered by a ladder.
Sergei looked at the sky.
From somewhere above drifted a
scraping of wood against metal,
a preemptory voice issuing
commands, "Move to the left,
make sure it's not crooked."
And after a minute,
the blows of a hammer.
Winter muffled each harsh burst
and cold snowy pockets before the
sounds could quite take their jagged
crow-like flights skyward.
The sky did not reverberate.
For it was immensely distant
and filter the brim with its
so unclear silent infinite music.
When the banging stopped,
the 2 pairs of legs
swerved back around them.
The door moaned an opening
and barked in closing.
The motor sneezed and
coughed and sped going past.
Then all was quiet.
A couple of people from
the line helped him up.
There was now a large sign
nailed above the kiosk.
It announced in bleached blue
letters, concert tickets,
too faded to have been
freshly painted,
a man in off at the door
noted with disapproval.
They must've taken it from some
old kiosk no longer in operation.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> People who have questions
should come to the microphones
that are in these 2 aisles.
And I would like to
start the question.
Olga, did you learn English in
school in Moscow and if you did,
how fluent was your English
when you came to Atlanta?
>> Well, I actually
started learning French.
In my family, my father spoke
French and my mother spoke English.
And we, early on, sort of
a family council decided
that French would be my language.
But luckily for me, I think my
father was a very impatient teacher.
And after a few sessions,
we decided that, "No, no,
I'll do English instead."
And my mother was a lot--
a lot more patient with me.
So, there was a little bit at home.
And then I started going to school
and we did have some English.
But eventually, I ended up at a
wonderful sort of special school
with a concentration in English
and we had very intensive English.
So, my English was fairly good.
I would say by the time I
came, definitely not fluent.
And I definitely struggled at first.
And I mean, I could understand
everything but it was far
from being what I wanted it to be.
And now when I reread my old college
papers, I am amazed with the amount
of basic grammar mistakes that
I made with those course, so.
>> You said you were--
you went to speak--
you went to, you know,
start to write English.
Now we're seeing a-- many
authors, they are being translated
from foreign languages into English,
have you ever thought instead
of changing English to start is just
translate some of your older books
or did you need to write with them?
>> You know, I thought about it.
And actually that was
the first thing I did.
I tried many different things.
It was a very painful process.
One of the things I did to switch to
English is I had this idea inspired
by Nabokov, learning the dictionary
from A to Z which is not a thing
to do and not recommended.
>> He did it and I actually
made it through the Zs.
And I always think if at any
point, anyone does a sort
of a scholarly study
of my vocabulary,
they will find an unusual
concentration
of obscure words starting with
As and Bs and maybe a little bit
of Cs and then it tapers off.
[Laughter] So there was that
and then, what I did was,
yes I did take some of my early
writings which were Russian,
some short stories and I
translated them in English.
And I even had a few
of them published.
But it just did not
sound like English.
It-- in fact, what I'm attempting to
do in my English is sort of use it
with the Russian intonation
and the paraphrases
of certain Russian
thought processes almost
and metaphors that are dear to me.
But the way you should do it just
sort of directly from Russian
to English, it does not work.
I have to think in English
in order for me to write
in English which is what I do.
And then, I just try to
bring in my Russian half.
>> Thank you.
>> Hello.
>> Hi.
>> My question is that, your
mother language is not English,
so how could you overcome
the difficulty
of a foreign language writing.
Because I have the same problem.
I'm from Iran and my
mother language is Farsi.
So, I'm here, I really
want to do something
in English but it's very difficult.
I mean, how could you
overcome the difficulties?
>> Well, I've just touched
on that a little bit.
I think you know, living
in the country,
thinking in the language,
helps a lot.
And I think that was really
the first step that, you know,
eventually, you-- and
sometimes I'm asked the question
that I always find very interesting,
what language do you dream in.
And there comes a point
where you stop dreaming
in your native language and start
dreaming in your new language.
And I think at that point,
it sort of becomes really
a part of who you are.
And it's really just immersion.
I mean, I-- and reading
a lot in the language,
and of course, experimenting.
You know, I did a lot of writing
that was quite funky before
I think I reached the point
where I'm comfortable
with my English.
>> Thank you.
>> Yes, good afternoon.
My name is Justin Williams and
I'm writing a horror novel.
I just wanted to know, how
is it that I can go by--
getting my book and published
without knowing anyone
in the business?
>> Well you know, actually
that's what I did.
I know it's-- there is
this belief or quite often,
I hear that it's impossible
to get published unless you
have a name in the industry.
You have to know someone.
Your-- I don't know, bestfriend has
to be married to an
agent or whatever.
That was not the case with me.
I never had taken a
single writing class ever.
I haven't known a single
writer, actually.
So, what I did is I got a
little thin book that said,
"How to break into writing."
I always think this is the best
10 dollars I've ever spent.
I think it's still available.
It's just a little, you know,
how to publish your writing.
And it tells you to double space
your manuscript and send it
out and-- which is what I did.
It was a great advice.
And after that, I got a few
credits publishing short stories.
I'm a very organized person.
I'm not a short story
writer by inclination.
I'm a novel-- I always
wanted to be a novelist.
I don't think I can ever fit what
I want to say into a short format
which I'm sure is a drawback
but-- and so-- but I told myself,
somehow 10 was the number for me,
that I will publish 10 short
stories just to publish them,
just to get my foot on the door.
And then once I published
10 stories,
then I'll turn to writing a novel.
And I knew what my
first novel would be.
You have to have something
that, you know, you care about.
And then, you just send it out and
hope for the best and you know--
it's worked for a lot of people
more than you would think.
>> Thank you.
I love your work also.
>> Oh, thank you so much.
>> You say you're very
organized person.
So, my question is--
>> I lied but--
[ Laughter ]
>> Well my question for you
on that is that, you know,
your process for writing,
coming up with the ideas,
you know, do you story board it?
Do you write an outline?
Do you write in the middle of
the night or early morning?
Do you have to be out of your
house in a different location?
>> That's-- yeah.
Well, on the ideas, I do keep
a kind of a writer's diary
which is not a diary of my
life but I've always kept it
and I don't write down
things that happen to me.
I write down ideas.
And I frequently go back and look
through different jots
of-- you know, of ideas.
And in fact, my idea for my first
novel, I went down through--
went through all-- when
I decided I was ready
to start writing my first novel,
I went back through by then,
making 20 volumes of these little
notebooks and pulled all the ideas
that seemed novel worthy, and then,
just focus on what
drew me in the best.
And then, yes, I do write an outline
at least for the first 2 books.
I absolutely did.
It's almost a chapter
by chapter outline.
You know, some writer say they kind
of just start writing with an image
or a character, and then it
takes them wherever it takes them
and the character surprised
them by doing something.
I think if my character
ever surprise me
by doing something
I didn't mean it--
him to do, I would be kind of upset.
So for me, it's organized.
But there is enough space and
enough air for it to breath.
So, it's not so sad.
It's not scene by scene.
It's kind of more of direction
of things and then, sometimes,
it does take you in sort
of unexpected directions.
And in the first book for instance,
there were a couple of chapters
that sort of popped out that
were not in the outline,
but just in a way, it
almost wrote themselves
and sometimes people say they
think these are the best chapters.
And they do feel different
from the rest of the writings.
So, from my second book, because of
that, I left a little more time--
I mean I left a little
more space in the outline.
It was a little more spontaneous,
like sort of a little more air.
So it's still-- you know,
maybe for the 3rd book,
I'm trying a different approach.
So, it kind of it's evolving.
>> It evolves.
So--
>> Thank you.
>> I think there's a lady there.
>> Oh, sorry, I didn't
realize there was a mic here.
>> You said you write in
English and then you work
in your Russian paraphrasing
and things like that,
do you ever find yourself either
consciously or unconsciously
as you go back and look
at your work later,
trying to correct misperceptions
or that kind of thing
about a different culture, a culture
that for a long time was in conflict
with the United States,
that kind of thing--
just kind of making it
humanizing that part of the world?
>> Well, I think, role of any writer
is to take something that they know
and bring it closer to other people.
And you know, you have to
sympathize with your character
and hopefully the reader will
sympathize with the character.
So, of course, I don't
do it consciously.
I don't consciously set out
to correct misperceptions
or certainly not-- I don't
have any messages in my work.
You know, I think that's more of the
domain of the nonfiction writers.
You inhabit your own
artistic creative world.
And you let your, sort
of fictional characters,
you know, do the talking for you.
Really, there's no message.
But certainly-- I mean, I
think that's a beautiful thing
about reading fiction is that, the
writer has a power to bring you
into his or her own world,
something that he or she knows
and that you will then, you
know, know better as well.
So, that hopefully.
>> It's up.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you so much, Olga.
Thank you.
>> Thank you very much.
Thank you everyone for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.